SPEAKER: After you have
launched your APIs on Apigee,
you will want to ensure they
are performing as expected
and services are
not interrupted.
This is where API
monitoring comes in.
It provides near
real-time insights
into API traffic and performance
to help you quickly diagnose
and solve issues as they arise.
One of the main purposes
of API monitoring
is to keep you informed
of unusual events
or patterns such as spikes
in traffic or latencies.
It enables you to create
notification alerts of changes
in API traffic so you can take
action before customers are
affected, increase
API availability,
reduce the time to
diagnose and issue,
use HTTP error codes
to speed diagnosis,
and isolate problem
areas quickly
by investigating errors,
performance, and latency issues
and their source.
It's important to note that
API monitoring only retains
data for the last 60 days.
This is because there may
be personally identifiable
information contained
in your data.
And so it is deleted per
the Google privacy policy
after that period.
[THREE TONES]
API monitoring is available
in the Navigation bar
under Analytics.
It provides three
different views
allowing you to display
timelines of recent API traffic
data, display recent
treemaps of data,
and investigate using
tables of API traffic data,
showing HTTP fault
codes by time, status,
and source by proxy.
In each of the views, you
have the same options.
You can change the view,
select the desired graphs,
and filter by the
environment, region,
and/or proxy by using the
respective drop-downs.
You can also adjust the period
to analyze a particular time
range.
Once you have identified
a particular issue,
you can create an alert to
be notified of the incident.
More on that later.
Let's continue
with our overview.
In the Timeline view, you have
graphs showing total traffic
requests during
one-minute intervals,
error rates as a percentage
of total traffic,
and latency for 50, 90,
95, and 99 percentiles.
You can drill down into
each for more details.
By hovering over the graphs,
you can see data values
at any point in time.
Data points are measured
at one-minute intervals.
The Recent view
enables you to view
treemaps of the
volume of traffic
by incident, error
rate, and latency.
It displays a proxy
traffic as blocks
that represent the volume of the
traffic by the size of the box.
The color of the
block in each graph
indicates the relative
sizes of the number
of incidents, error rate, and
the maximum 50th percentile
latency.
Clicking on a block displays the
distribution in the right pane
by HTTP status codes,
fault codes, fault source,
and region.
Hovering over a block
displays the proxy name,
total traffic, and error rate.
The Investigate view displays
pivot tables of metrics
and attributes for
all API traffic
to help you compare activity
for different metrics.
By default, the Investigate
view displays three tables--
fault code by time, fault
code by status code,
and fault source by proxy.
As in the other
views, you can select
any combination of tables to
aid in your investigation.
There are more tables to
choose from in this view.
Selecting a cell with a
value shows the distribution
in the pane on the right as
it did in the recent view.
You can select the pivot table
to change its orientation
to get a different perspective.
Now that we understand
the different views,
let's take a quick look at
alerts, where you can configure
notifications to be sent to
your preferred communication
channels such as email
or SMS, et cetera.
Alerts are triggered when a
specified event or condition
is met, which are
called incidents.
Let's create an alert.
Clicking on the Alert link
takes us to the GCP console
where we can figure
alerts and notifications.
For example, to set up an
alert for high-traffic volume,
you first select Add Condition
and then select the resource
type for the target.
Then select a metric
such as proxy request,
cumulative request.
Next, select Aggregator
as sum and then a period
of one minute.
Clicking Add takes
us back to the Wizard
where we can proceed
to the next steps.
Select an existing notification
channel from the dropdown
and be sure to check mark
Notify an incident closure
to know when the alert clears.
Enter a descriptive
alert and instructions,
such as a documentation link.
When an incident is fired,
you'll get a notification.
And when things return
to a healthy state,
you'll get another
notification that the incident
has been cleared.
Back in the GCP
console, you'll be
able to see the
history of incidents
that occurred specifically
when they were opened
and when they were closed.
And there you have it.
A quick walkthrough of how to
use the power of API monitoring
and how it can keep your
API program running smoothly
and your API consumers happy.
If you found this episode
helpful, community,
you can subscribe to learn
about more of our episodes
on "Getting Started with
Apigee's API Management Tool
Set."
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]